[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans 100 % Sénat mardi les députés ont
très largement adopter le projet de loi
qui inscrit dans la Constitution la
liberté garantie pour les femmes d'avoir
recours à l'IVG le texte doit maintenant
être étudié au Sénat c'est dans ce
contexte que la délégation aux droits
des femmes du Sénat auditionne Éric
Dupont Moretti le garde des sauts des
questions lui seront bien évidemment
posées à ce sujet mais la délégation a
aussi des questions sur les violences
sexistes et sexuel et sur les familles
monoparentales
écoutez non je veux d'abord vous dire
que c'est un grand un grand plaisir pour
moi d'être parmi vous ce matin et euh de
vous
euh
retrouver en cette année
nouvelle petite parenthèse l'officier de
police judiciaire qui dit à une
qui demande à une victime si elle a
éprouvé du
plaisir pardon ce n'est pas mon
périmètre mais je me demande franchement
ce qu'il fait dans la
police et quand j'entends ce que vous me
dites les oreilles m tombent et je pense
que si les choses se précisaient et
qu'elles étaient transmises à Gérald
hermanin je pense qu'il n'hésiterait pas
une seule seconde à tirer les
conséquences qui méritent d'être tiré
d'un tel comp
insupportable d'entendre des choses
pareilles
aujourd'hui ce qui signifie au fond
c'est une transition comme disent
les commentateur
radiophoni que le combat n'est pas
terminé reste encore beaucoup de Boul à
faire et que le chemin est encore long
donc je suis ravi de de reprendre avec
vous ce dialogue il est
indispensable naturellement je connais
votre engagement total
madame la
Présidente mesames les sénatrices et on
va je vais essayer de répondre le plus
complètement possible aux questions
que légitimement vous me
posez bon votre délégation est pour moi
une interlocutrice si j'ose dire
absolument et une partenaire absolument
privilégié et je vais en venir tout de
suite au sujet qui nous mobilise et qui
nous
préoccupe la protection des droits des
femmes passe
évidemment en matière de justice par la
lutte contre les violences faites à la
rcontre alors les bilan sont sont
encourageants mais les mots doivent être
mesurés personne ne peut faire de de de
culturisme judicière évidemment
et une violence un
féminicide c'est toujours une violence
et un féminicide de trop là aussi c'est
une évidence les travaux parlementaires
récents permettent de souligner qu'en
matière de violence
intrafamiliale on est engagé de manière
irréversible pour faire reculer ce ce
fléo
indigne et je vais me concentrer si vous
voulez bien sur les chantiers résolument
engager mon CAP est clair ma
détermination est totale il faut
détecter
plutôt pourquoi je le dis parce que la
justice évidemment ne peut pas
intervenir si elle n'est pas saisie si
elle n'est pas alertée si son attention
n'a pas été attirée il faut protéger les
victimes tout au long de la procédure
tout en développant simultanément bien
sûr la prise en
charge renforcer des
auteurs cette lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales repose désormais sur des
réponses et sur des réformes qui sont
profondes et qui sont effectives al je
vais vous annoncer d'abord que en
2023 le nombre de drames
évités grâce au bracelet
antiraapprochement a été multiplié par 3
passant de
3634 en 2022 à près de
10500 interventions des forces de
l'ordre que je veux évidemment remercier
c'est ant de femmes sauvées
d'enfants d'enfants
sauvés toujours sur
ces pardonnez-moi sur ces outils de de
protection téléphonees grave danger ont
eux aussi permis d'éviter 2500 drames en
2022 les ordonnances de protection ont
également permis de sauver des vies
elles étaient prononcées bon vous le
savez en 42 jours c'est désormais 6
jours et ce sera dans quelques jours pas
dire dans quelques heures 24 heur grâce
à votre proposition madame la Présidente
de en cas d'urgence urgence détecté par
le procureur de la République alors par
ailleurs une avancée majeure vient
d'être votée à l'Assemblée nationale
grâce au groupe modem s'agit de rétablir
une justice
patrimoniale ce texte sera prochainement
soumis au Sénat l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et la lutte contre
les violences conjugales
euh se doivent d'être menés sur tous les
fronts ce texte permet de
d'éviter que l'auteur d'un homicide à
l'encontre de son
conjoint puisse bénéficier du régime
matrimonial on avait déjà réglé la
question de l'héritage et voyez parfois
les choses
que l'on a sous les yeux et qui sont
évidentes au fond il a fallu que l'un de
vos collègues dise mais
euh le bénéfice du régime matrimonial
personne ne se dit que il est impossible
qu'il viennent bénéficier à l'auteur
d'un
meurtre et ce texte évidemment emporté
l'adhésion euh du garde des saut aussi
parce que c'était tellement logique et
tellement évident que personne ne
l'avait vu et donc ce texte a été porté
par moi avec enthousiasme et il a fait
l'objet d'un consensus très très large
et je pense que on retrouvera le même
consensus devant votre
assemblée tous les champs de
l'intervention judiciaire doivent être
exploités absolument tous et c'est cette
approche
globale autour d'une même situation
familiale qui est
consacré dans les textes de novembre
2023 qui portte évidemment création des
pôles vifs dans toutes les juridictions
dans tous les tribunaux dans toutes les
cours d'appel euh ce texte est effectif
depuis euh la mise en place de ces pô
spécialisés euh est désormais une
réalité depuis le 1er
janvier cette réforme a été par
particulièrement bien accueilli
euh par les magistrats
euh grâce aux travaux préparatoires qui
ont été conduits dans la mission que
vous avez mené madame la Présidente au
côté de la députée Émilie chandlerur on
est passé
d'une proposition de loi je m'y arrête
un quart de
seconde qui tendait à créer
des tribunaux spécialisés
à avec un travail qui était qui n'était
pas achevé qui n'était pas abouti les
magistrats étaient totalement hostiles à
cette création en revanche ils ont
parfaitement accueilli les pôles
[Musique]
spécialisés si on peut résumer ce que
sont ces pôles spécialisés bonjour
monsieur le sénateur c'est en
réalité l'idée que ne peut plus et qu'on
ne peut pas fonctionner en silo et que
tout le monde doit se parler euh force
de sécurité intérieure évidemment mais
aussi euh parquet juge d'application des
peines juge aux affaires familiales et
cetera et cetera c'est l'antiérgac si je
je je puis euh me permettre de de
résumer les
choses j'ai souhaité m'inspirer de vos
recommandations pour consacrer
l'articulation indispensable entre
procédure civil et procédure pénal ça
aussi c'était deux silos
distincts qui fonctionnit en parallèle
et qui mérite grâce à une organisation
dédiée et spécialisée de de se parler et
d'échanger on évite à l'évidence des
situations qui sont dramatiques et
irréversibles en fait ces pô spécialisé
constituent un message très fort envoyé
à toutes les victimes euh
qui mérite bien sûr un accompagnement
spécifique et un jugement adapté à la
complexité de ces violences vous avez
souligné madame la Présidente
l'importance de la formation de tous les
acteurs
judiciaires et l'exemple que vous nous
avez donné illustre à quel
point il y a encore dans les esprits des
choses qui mériteraient d'être balayé si
j'ose dire d'un d'un vrai revers de
manche pour ne pas dire d'un d'un grand
coup de balai mais
mais retenir que il y a aussi beaucoup
de bonne
volonté que naturellement les formations
des enquêteurs des magistrats des
greffiers des avocats également et de
tous les partenaires je pense aux
associations je pense aux soignants je
pense aux services sociaux tout cela est
absolument indispensable et je partage
totalement votre occupation que j'ai
souhaité d'ailleurs consacrer dans une
circulaire que j'ai signé en novembre le
24 novembre
2023 ainsi les membres des pôles
spécialisés participeront à des actions
de formation local organisées au plus
proche et au plus près des acteurs de
terrain ce qui intègre évidemment toutes
les évolutions récentes normatives et
les nouveaux outils de protection les
magistrats vont pouvoir s'appuyer sur
des moyens numériques dédiés avec
l'applicatif
SP système informatisé de suivi de
politique pénale
prioritaire autorisé par décret du 10
octobre 2023 cet outil
indispensable centralise l'ensemble des
données relatives aux situations
familial issu à la fois des procédures
civiles mais aussi des procédures
pénales et les informations échangées
dans le cadre des comités de pilotage il
est doté de fonctionnalité de pilot des
mesures de protection de mécanismes
d'alerte automatisé et
personnalisable de radars en matière de
protection de l'enfance ou
lors de la sortie de détention ce qui
était une préoccupation très très forte
évidemment des
victimes qui ne peuvent pas vivre dans
la crainte tout simplement
exprimer vous l'avez relevé madame la
Présidente l'intervention judiciaire en
matière de vif est très dépendant de la
réactivité de ses partenaires et ça
implique évidemment une coordination
interministérielle à tous les
niveaux bien sûr une coordination à un
niveau politique c'est bien le sens du
plan
gouvernemental renouvelé le 8 mars
dernier désormais piloté par ma collègue
Aurore berger dont la détermination je
le crois est connue de toutes et de
tous quatre axes majeurs lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes égalité
professionnelle économique santé des
femmes et la culture de l'égalité qui
engage évidemment toutes nos
administrations sans exception alors
j'entends votre inquiétude sur la
réalité de cette coordination et je veux
vous assurer que nous avons engager une
profonde
révolution je vous le dis sans en
coordination effective nous ne serions
jamais parvenus à déployer 5500 TGD en
2023 contre seulement je vous demande de
retenir ce chiffre 976 en 2020
l'évolution elle est extrêmement
importante plus
de plus de 1000 barres en seulement 2
ans 145 unités d'accueil pédiatrique
enfants SANS DANGER pour protéger les
enfants
cictimes nous avions envisagé un nuaped
par département nous souhaitons
désormais un nuaped par ressort
judiciaire dont il est vrai que c'est un
outil
absolument performant dont plus personne
ne pourrait songer à
eu à se passer
euh nous ne serions jamais parvenus a
absorbé une augmentation de plus de 123
% du nombre de condamnations des auteurs
impliquant une prise en charge
disciplinaire s'il y avait pas cette
mobilisation totale alors de nombreuses
instructions conjointes engageant
plusieurs ministères ont vu le jour et
sont a autant d'illustration de cette
coordination circulaire
interministérielle du 25 novembre 2021
ayant permis les dépôts de plaintes et
le recueil de preuves au sein des
établiss de
santé bon l'utilité je je veux pas m'y
arrêter tout le monde imagine que c'est
extrêmement douloureux de devoir répéter
les choses et cetera en réalité c'est
les enquêteurs c'est la justice c'est la
médecine médecine
légale qui vient vers la victime et pas
l'inverse et c'est une
évolution
majeur dans les pratiques qui sont les
nôtres dans le prolongement j'ai signé
en mai
2023 la convention permettant le
déploiement national d'un lieu de prise
en charge globale des victimes à
l'INSTAT du dispositif maison des femmes
au côté des ministres de l'intérieur et
du ministre de la
Santé circulaire d'avril
2022 conjointe là encore signée avec le
ministère de la Santé permettant le
déploiement du protocole féminicide
consacré
à la prise en charge immédiate des
enfants présents
euh pendant le pendant le
drame témoin de ces violences et cet
enfant témoin est est devenu un enfant
victime je me souviens de ce que
dit serulnique qui dit qu'un enfant qui
assiste à des
violences subit un traumatisme digne de
d'une scène de guerre en réalité son psy
me est évidemment totalement déchiré par
ce qu'il par ce dont il a été le témoin
chaque avancée dans le champ judiciaire
est est systématiquement intégrée dans
une action coordonnée avec mes autres
collègues du gouvernement et ma priorité
je je veux le redire
ici absolu est une bonne application des
lois par le ministère de la Justice
évidemment et par l'ensemble des
services de l'État cette articulation
interministérielle
est en outre garanti au sein du
ministère de la Justice grâce à un
pilotage interne que j'ai confié à la
haute fonctionnaire à l'égalité des
droits dont la Cour des comptes a salué
le positionnement à haut
niveau pas tous les jours qu'on reçoit
des compliments de la Cour des comptes
et donc quand on reçoit des compliments
de la Cour des comptes il faut savoir
les apprécier à leur juste très juste
valeur un mot madame la Présidente si
vous me le permettez sur la lutte contre
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes depuis 2017 la France est
pleinement engagée politiquement comme
juridiquement dans la mise en œuvre
concrète d'une législation sévère et
efficace pour réprimer toutes les formes
de violence sexuelle avec la
détermination et la rigueur nécessaire
vous avez voté des avancées législatives
qui à mes yeux sont déterminantes qui
conforent la place de la France pour
faire avancer les droits des victimes de
violence sexuelle je pense en
particulier à la loi du 3 août 2018 qui
a renforcé la répression du
cyber du cyber harcèlement et créer les
infraction d'outrage sexiste ainsi que
le délit de voyurisme je pense aussi à
la loi du 21 avril
2021 porté par madame la sénatrice
billon qui renforce la protection des
mineurs victimes sans renverser la
charge de la preuve en fixant un âge en
desessin duquel un mineur ne peut
consentir un acte
sexuel je prendre ici un instant pour
éclairer les controverses qui conduisent
de manière à mon sens injustifiée à
conclure à l'inaction de notre
justice depuis
2017 le nombre d'affaires nouvelles de
viol
portait la connaissance des procureurs
de la République est en constante
augmentation
ainsi
personnes ont été mises en cause dans
des affaires de viol orienté par les
parquets en 2022
contre
1294 une
affaire personne mise en cause
pardonnez-moi en 2017 c'est précis une
augmentation de 104
% lorsque les faits sont caractérisés et
l'auteeur identifié la réponse pénale
est je le dis systématique j'ai donné
dès février 2021 instruction au
procureur de poursuivre l'enquête y
compris mesdames monsieur le sénateur
lorsque les faits apparaissent prescrits
ce qui per
de
découvrir d'autres
victimes le nombre de condamnations de
majeur pour viol a augmenté de 30 %
depuis
2017 passant de 960 en 2017 à
1260 en
2022 le nombre de condamnations de
majeur pour agression sexuelle était de
5 617 en
2017 il est de
485 en 2022 et la progression est encore
plus importante s'agissant des
condamnations pour viole incestueux
commis sur un
mineur c'est une progression de 129 %
entre 2017 et 2021 passant de 177 à 405
les condamnations pour agression
sexuelle inesteuse ou atteinte sexuelle
incestueuse ont progressé quant à elle
de 91 % passant de
675 à
1290 un dernier chiffre sur le quantum
des peines prononcé en matière de viol
il est de 11 ans en
moyenne et c'est un des quantums les
plus importants les plus élevés
d'Europe enfin je veux indiquer qu'il
est impossible en l'état de nos donnes
d'établir un pourcentage de classement
comparer le nombre de plaintes et de
condamnation est ilusoire car ce ne sont
pas les mêmes procédures qui sont
comptabilisées et ce serait nié les
exigences probatoires fondamentale dans
notre État de droit permettant de
poursuivre et de condamner évidemment
les auteurs on peut pas conclure à
l'inaction de la justice ni à son
impunité les chiffres en sont euh me
semble-t-il les pousstouflantes
démonstration et je veux mettre en garde
tous ceux qui publiquement tiennent ce
discours mais au-delà de la critique on
est habitué euh à être critiqué mais ce
qui me chagrine le plus c'est que c'est
susceptible de décourager bon nombre de
victimes qui se finalement euh qu'on
laisse dans une espèce d'aquabonisme ah
ben ça sert à rien parce que la justice
ne condamne pas parce que la justice
n'enquiète pas parce que la justice et
cetera je vous ai donné un certain
nombre de chiffres je souhaite vraiment
mettre un terme à à à à à ces choses qui
sont dites et qui ont surtout comme
effet délétaire et dévastateur le fait
de
démobiliser des victimes qui
souhaiteraient déposer plainte et qui se
disent à quoi bon ce discours euh est un
discours euh absolument contreproductif
entendre à longueur de plateau de télé
porter plainte ça sert à rien que la
justice fait rien euh quel est l'axiste
voilà c'est absolument insupportable ça
n'est pas conforme à la réalité et moi
je veux dire au aux victimes portez
plainte et saisissez la justice
évidemment tout n'est pas
parfait mais nous faisons tout et
j'allais dire tous ensemble pour que les
choses bougent
et qu'elles aillent dans le bon sens on
doit poursuivre les efforts pour
accueillir la parole des victimes pour
la respecter l'accueillir et la
respecter et pour moi les choses vont
évidemment de de paire du dépôt de la
plainte à l'issue de la procédure pénale
et il faut évidemment redonner aux
victimes confiance dans l'institution
judiciaire on a des résultats avec la
mise en place des cours criminells
départementales partie des questions que
légitimement madame la Présidente vous
me posé dont la généralisation je
rappelle est effective depuis janvier
2023 on sait déjà
que les crimes sexuels qui constituent
90 % des affaires renvoyées devant les
Cours criminel sont jugés plus vite et
permettent de faire baisser les
correctionnalisations
correctionnalisation pour une victime
c'est
insupportable elle sait ce qu'elle a
vécu elle a vécu un viol c'est c'est
comme ça que ces fait méritent d'être
qualifié et on dit à un moment à la
victime vous allez être jugé devant le
tribunal correctionnel c'est quelque
chose que les victimes ne supportent pas
et on peut
entendre leur désarroi leur
désappointement je crois d'ailleurs que
les mots ne sont pas justes la moyenne
du délai d'audiencement mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur des
dossiers d'accusé détenus est en effet
de 5 de 6 pardonnez-moi vir5 mois et de
8,7 mois pour les accusé libre ce qui
est particulièrement bref au regard en
particulier des 18 mois en moyenne du
délai d'audiencement aux assises si
j'ose dire classique sur les h premiers
cours les h premières cours
expérimentales on a remarqué une
augmentation des cision criminelle rendu
de plus de 50 % et c'est un chiffre
énorme et je précise que le taux
d'acquitement est le même que pour les
cours d'assise environ 5 % c'est que sur
le terrain probatoire nous sommes à
égalité
entre ces deux
juridictions évidemment on n' pas achevé
notre mission pour mieux protéger les
victimes en amont et en aval de
l'intervention de la
justice et depuis 3 ans j'ai porté une
augmentation des moyens consacrés à
l'aide aux victimes euh au profit de nos
associations
partenaires vous avez ainsi voté un
budget alloué à l'aide aux victimes de
47 millions en
2024 contre 26 millions en 2017 sur une
augmentation de 80 %. alors faut-il
changer à nouveau la loi pénale au
regard des débats actuels sur la
définition du viol
les débats récents parfois virulents
imposent de livrer une lecture honnête
et rigoureuse sur notre
législation d'abord la législation
française en matière de viol est sans
doute la plus répressive
d'Europe 15 ans de réclusion criminelle
jusqu'à la
perpétuité avec un certain nombre de
circonstances aggravante lorsque
l'Espagne qui est toujours une référence
fixe une peine de 6 à 12 ans depuis
2022 notre définition du viol protège
les victimes et permet de sanctionner
lourdement les auteurs s'attachant à
démontrer la responsabilité de
l'agresseur qui impose une relation
sexuelle non consentie le juge est
évidemment le garant de la liberté notre
droit permet de condamner lourdement en
appréciant concrètement l'absence de
consentement des victimes la preuve est
rapporté par l'accusation et par
personne
d'autre est-ce le rôle de la loi pénale
que de définir le consentement d'une
victime au lieu de s'attacher à définir
la responsabilité du criminel voilà
comment les choses méritent d'être dites
et les questions méritent d'être posées
avec des risque de glissement vers une
contractualisation des relations
sexuelles dont je le crois personne ne
veut et je veux ici mettre en garde
quant au risque de braquer la
focale sur la victime alors que le seul
responsable c'est le violeur le risque
majeur est de faire peser la preuve du
consentement sur la
victime aussi moi j'appelle à la plus
grande prudence ce que veulent les
victimes et nous devons y répondre c'est
des procédures plus
rapides des procédures
compréhensibles une meilleure
information à tous les stades de la
procédure mais également une une
information pour le grand public qui
peut désormais appréhender la complexité
de ses affaires grâce à une loi que vous
avez porté qui permet de filmer les
audiences qui permet certain nombre de
nos compatriotes de bien comprendre ce
que sont les mécanismes judiciaires et
la difficulté de rendre la justice c'est
toujours mieux que le prisme de la fit
diversification qu'on nous offre en 35
secondes sur certaines chaînes pour dire
que la justice ne fonctionne pas en
général d'ailleurs sont pas des juristes
qui font les commentaires peu importe je
ferme la parenthèse il est intéressant
de savoir que le fait de que la justice
se donne à voir permet de mieux
l'appréhender de mieux la comprendre et
de la critiquer d'une façon qui n'est
pas une façon niéliste prise en charge
globale des auteurs car les violences
faites aux femmes qu'elles soit intime
ou sur la voie publique appelle des
réponses spécifiques
intégrant des démarches de
soin je voudrais vous convaincre de ma
totale détermination à combler toutes
les failles ou lacunes relevant tant des
pratiques professionnelles que de la
loi encore une fois bon chaque
infraction chaque viol chaque
féminicide est un échec pour toute notre
notre société
mais chaque
plainte transmise au parquet est en soit
un progrès et si la justice n'est pas
saisie je l'ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
une évidence mais parfois il faut redire
les évidences si la justice n'est pas
saisie naturellement elle ne peut pas
intervenir alors la justice n'a pas d'
priori dans notre pays souvent lorsque
les procédures sont classé bah disons-le
c'est faute de preuve pas
comment faut identification de
l'auteur tout cela c'est une constante
c'est tout un système probatoire c'est
c'est l'état de droit c'est le
fonctionnement judiciaire tel
que tel qu'il doit être consacré et ça
ne veut pas dire que les faits n'ont pas
eu lieu mais simplement qu'ils n'ont pas
pu être démontré en justice et il nous
faut inciter les victimes à déposer
plainte le plus vite possible pour pour
cela éducon nos enfants et tous les
adultes à identifier toutes les
situations de violence sexuelle car nous
disposons je je pense d'un vaste arsenal
législatif pour y répondre alors
s'agissant de la position de la France
sur la directive
européenne en
réalité il s'agit d'un débat de
compétence alors je sais que certains
ont instrumentalisé ce
débat pour dire que la France ne voulait
pas que la France n'avait pas envie que
la France était
rétrograde c'est d'abord c'est surtout
et c'est à nos yeux uniquement un débat
de
compétence c'est un débat de de
compétence de l'Union et un débat de
doctrine et on va le dire très
clairement les
juristes ne sont pas d'accord entre eux
il est tout à fait clair qu'à ce stade
des
négociations il est primordial de ne
prendre aucun risque sur un texte qui
pourrait être annulé par la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne et plutôt
que d'avoir avancer encore que je le dis
notre législation est la plus répressive
d'Europe les femes F alors aurait
beaucoup perdu parce que si le texte
devait être
censuré et
bien ceux qui je le redis parfois des
fins politiciennes instrumentalist ce
débat
seraiit les responsables d'un recul
absolument historique que moi je
n'envisage pas une
seconde de de supporter nous avons une
législation nous sommes très clairs dans
notre
législation prendre des risques et
encourir la censure de la Cour de
justice de
l'Union c'est un risque que moi je ne
veux pas prendre les femmes ont besoin
de sécurité juridique le texte européen
comporte des avancées
majeur qu'il ne faut pas
fragiliser
j'aimerais à
présent évoquer un chantier historique
qui est celui de l'inscription de l'IVG
dans notre
Constitution j'aurai l'honneur de me
présenter devant vous
prochainement avec ce projet de loi
constitutionnel relatif à la liberté de
recourir à
l'interruption
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
adopté il y a quelques jours par
l'Assemblée
nationale à une majorité c'est un petit
clin d'œil de badin que je vous adresse
non pas des tr5e mais des
[Musique]
9/10e ce projet il est à l'évidence un
point d'équilibre entre les nombreux
travaux qui ont été engagés dans les
deux chambres et le Sénat
a été c'est bien
normal plus que respecté dans la
préparation de cette version de
compromis comment puis-je le dire
simplement l'écriture proposée par le
gouvernement est à 95 % celle du
Sénat je dis 95 pour faire chiffre
rond pourra dire
[Musique]
98,5 donc on a entendu le scénna
évidemment
on a deux textes qui sont différents on
a cherché le point d'équilibre le point
de
compromis je pense que
l'enjeu ne permette aucune
instrumentalisation politicienne et je
n'envisage en aucune
façon
que de telles choses puissent traverser
les
esprits le projet de loi et comporte une
disposition unique qui a pour objet de
modifier l'article 34 de la Constitution
en y ajoutant après le 17e alinéa un
alinéa ainsi rédigé la
loi détermine les conditions dans
lesquelles s'exerce la liberté garantie
à la femme d'avoir recours à une
interruption volontaire de
grossesse je veux rassurer toutes celles
et tous ceux qui craignent que ce projet
ne consacre un droit absolu et sans
limite non ça n'est évidemment pas ce
que nous
voulons non ce n'est pas ce que fait le
texte le terme
garantie seule concession faite à
l'Assemblée
nationale seule quand je disais tout à
l'heure 95 % peut augmenter en encore le
chiffre n'emporte pas la création d'un
droit opposable absolu sans limite et ça
n'est pas moi mesdames les sénatrices
monsieur le sénateur qui le dit c'est le
Conseil d'État dans un avis dont je vous
recommande à toutes euh à vous monsieur
le sénateur la lecture parce qu'il est
particulièrement étayé il précise que
j'ouvre les guillemets à cet instant
par elle-même l'inscription de la
liberté de recourir à une IVG dans la
Constitution dans les termes que propose
le gouvernement ne remet pas en cause
les autres droits et libertés que la
Constitution garantit tel que notamment
la liberté de conscience qui soutend la
liberté des médecins et sages femmes de
ne pas pratiquer une IVG
ainsi que la liberté d'expression et par
ailleurs je veux que la liberté de
recourir à
l'IVG je constate que cette liberté n'a
pas été consacrée au niveau
constitutionnel contrairement d'ailleurs
à ce que l'on pourrait penser d'emblé il
y a toute une analyse du Conseil d'État
qui rappelle que tant sur le plan
national que que supranational
Convention européenne de sauvegarde des
droits de l'homme jurisprudence de la
Cour européenne jurisprudence de la Cour
de justice la loi veille n'est pas
constitutionnellement protégée voilà
cette analyse encore une fois elle n'est
pas mienne elle n'est pas partisane elle
est le fruit d'une
réflexion portée par le Conseil d'État
et exprimé en des termes qui sont des
termes je les ai qualifié comme tel et
je le refais en des termes
lumineux alors euh euh le Conseil
d'État nous rappelle qu'en revanche le
principe de sauvegarde de la dignité de
la personne humaine a été
consacré comme principe à valeur
constitutionnelle par une décision du
Conseil constitutionnel de
1994 et qu'il en va de même du principe
de liberté de conscience des médecins
consacré comme principe fondamental
reconnu par les lois de la République
par une décision du constitutionnel de
2001 dignité de la personne consacrée au
plus haut niveau liberté de conscience
consacré au plus haut niveau et
liberté garantie à la femme
d'avorter ne serait pas protégé de la
même façon comprenez bien que dans le
triptique là il nous manque un élément
et cet élément c'est la protection
constitutionnelle que je souhaiterais
que nous
puissions tous ensemble de façon
transpartisane euh mettre en œuvre et
mettre en place et pour dire les chose
clairement la sauvegarde de la dignité
humaine la liberté de conscience des
médecins ont déjà valeurs
constitutionnelles voilà et la liberté
d'avoir recours à l'IVG
non
bon cette seule question
et et la réponse à cette seule question
devrait me semble-t-il nous inciter à
adopter le texte alors j'entends
évidemment les crainte quant à notre
Constitution qui deviendrait selon une
formule désormais consacrée un catalogue
sans cohérence des droits sociaux et
sociétaux bon très
clairement sur ces
sujets
sociétau
philosophique je respect évidemment
l'opinion de toutes et de tous pas
contraindre les
consciences je pense que nous le savons
la liberté de penser c'est quelque chose
qui est important pour
autant la
Constitution pardon de le dire ainsi
dispose déjà de
nombreux droits et libertés et c'est
même une de ses fonctions majeures
réunir l'ensemble des droits et
libertés ulèrement
important la seule question qui vous
sera posée le 28 février prochain c'est
la liberté de recourir à l'IVG
recouvret-elle à vos yeux une importance
suffisante pour être protégé par notre
Constitution voilà comment à ce
stade je me permets de poser la la
question et c'est à vous en tant que
constituant qu'il appartiendra bien sûr
de de répondre et vous l'aurez compris
en ce qui me concerne la réponse c'est
oui et à ceux qui répondent que l'IVG
n'est pas menacé en
France je dis que on n'écrit pas la
Constitution pour le présent on l'écrit
d'abord et surtout pour l'avenir et
c'est le propre même de notre loi
suprême
elle a pour vocation à duré
elle a pour vocation de de valoir pour
l'avenir en protégeant évidemment nos
droits mais regardons
vers un horizon qui peut-être un horizon
éloigné et les expériences
étrangères en la matière nous démontre
que rien n'est acquis
voilà par revenir sur ce qui s'est passé
outre
atlantique pas revenir sur ce qui s'est
passé en Europe où l'on a contraint des
femmes à entendre les battements de cœur
de du fétus qu'elle portait pour les
dissuader d'avorter mes yeux une torture
insupportable alors vous m'avez posé une
question précise madame la Présidente
s'agissant du calendrier alors j'ai
précisé lors du vote de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a quelques jours que nous
prendrions le temps et qu'il faut aller
au bout de cette révision alors je sais
les mois qui a pu provoquer l'évocation
d'une date de congrès avant même que les
chambres ne se soit prononcé
oui mais je je je je avant de dire que
c'est pas malin ce que je je voudrais je
voudrais vous dire deux mots là-dessus
sur l'expression non non mais sur sur
sur les choses qui ont été dites et en
particulier sur les choses qui ont été
dites par le Président de la
République ces choses elles ont été
dites monsieur le sénateur lors des
rencontres de Saint-Denis et le
président de la République dit
précisément
ceci un examen dans chaque assemblée
pourra avoir
lieu au 1er trimestre
2024 afin qu'un congrès puisse être
envisagé le 4 mars
alors le 4 mars prochain mais pardon
vous dites c'est pas malin et moi je dis
et moi je dis c'est à la fois
respectueux et prudent bon voilà mais
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce que
franchement alors
voyez une perception des choses
naturellement pour le coup différente et
et et partisane mais est-ce que ça
mérite que cette
réforme ne soit pas envisagée pour des
questions de c'est pas
malin moi je dis c'est c'était très
prudent je je je je vous ai relu
exactement ce que le président de la
République a exprimé est-ce que sur une
réforme aussi importante que celle-là
sur une liberté aussi importante que
celle-là pour toutes les femmes de notre
pays le fait que nous soyons si alors je
je je vais y mettre je vais abandonner
le le le mode indicatif monsieur le
sénateur pour ne pas vous froisser
utiliser tous les conditionnels qui vont
bien tous les si toutes les virgules
tous les trois points de suspension ok
mais franchement de quoi parle-t-on on
parle d'une liberté fondamentale pour
les femmes et puis et puis nous serions
le le premier pays à inscrire cela dans
notre
Constitution bon voil après chacun sera
avec sa conscience et moi je ne veux pas
violer les consciences je n'en ai pas
les moyens je suis parfaitement
respectueux du travail
parlementaire je peux rien vous dire
d'autre mesurons les
enjeux nous avons des choses d'ors et
déjà garanti par notre Constitution sauf
l'essentiel qui est la liberté de la
femme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure dans
dans ce dans ce triptique que je regarde
avec beaucoup d'objectivité c'est un
travail de de d'analyse auquel
d'ailleurs a procédé le Conseil d'État
je trouve assez désolant
que nous ne consacrions pas mais j'ai la
conviction
que au-delà des
susceptibilités qui peuvent s'exprimer
au
fond et heureusement qu'ell
s'exprime nous irons vers l'essentiel et
l'essentiel c'est de garantir aux femmes
une liberté qui est celle de disposer de
leur corps pas plus compliqué que
ça donc moi je veux vous rassurer madame
la Présidente mais je pense que vous
n'êtes pas inquiète
on prendra le temps qu'il faudra pour
aller au bout de cette révision parce
que je pense profondément qu'elle est
indispensable
voilà je veux redire ici que nous avons
tout fait mais vraiment tout fait pour
que l'écriture proposée dans ce projet
de révision soit accepté par une
majorité de sénateurs parce que ce
projet c'est pas une initiative du
gouvernement seul vous le savez il
arrive après de nombreuses initiatives
parlementaires neuf initiatives
parlementaires je crois bon
euh nous nous sommes dans une forme
n non non
mais et je dis le contraire d'ailleurs
on parle d'initiative parlementaire nous
nous avions dit dans un premier temps le
président de la République avait dit
nous regardons les initiatives
parlementaires et puis nous nous nous
ferons quelque chose de cela
bon au fond mais je ne veux heurter
aucune sensibilité c'est une forme de 3è
lecture et le gouvernement a pris je
l'ai déjà a dit la la quasi intégralité
de l'écriture du Sénat alors moi je dis
tout simplement faut pas rater ce moment
euh il faut pas rater cette alignement
des
planètes et pour conclure je je je veux
saluer madame la Présidente je pense
avoir été complet sur cette question je
veux saluer les les les travaux en cours
qui sont menés par votre délégation
relativement aux familles
monoparentales réalité sociale elle
touche très majoritairement les femmes
et elles accentuent évidemment leur
précarisation et tout cela doit être
prise en compte dans le traitement
judiciaire alors vous m'interrogez sur
les disparités
jurisprudentielle ainsi que sur le
faible montant de la pension alimentaire
fixé judiciaairement bon le juge aux
affaires familiales il se fondent sur
des critères qui ont été fixés par la
loi pardonnez-moi par la la loi
notamment c'est l'article
371- 2 de notre Code civil pour
déterminer le montant de la contribution
à l'entretien et l'éducation des
enfants ressources du parent débiteur et
du parent créancier charge du parent
débiteur du parent créancier besoin de
l'enfant et afin d'accompagner le juge
dans la fixation du montant de cette
contribution un référentiel indicatif
fait l'objet d'une diffusion publique
accessible au justiciaable c'est un
simulateur qui est accessible sur notre
site Internet ainsi que
sur toute nouvelle application
justice.fr que je vous recommande de
télécharger et au total ce sont plus de
1000 personnes par jour qui utilisent ce
simulateur
c'est une petite fierté que de l'avoir
mise en place il y a des des femmes qui
aujourd'hui on le sait
euh ne peuvent pas ne veulent pas
n'osent pas quitter un conjoint avec
lequel ell
vivent des jours bien tristes parce
qu'elles se disent mais comment je vais
faire pour élever le gamin et cet outil
permet aux femmes d'avoir une simulation
immédiate de ce à quoi elle pourrait
prétendre en terme de pension
alimentaire alors ça ne règle pas la
question du rééquilibrage je dois dire
mais vous le savez toutes et tous
que le garde des saau ne peut pas donner
de directive peut pas le faire auprès
d'un procureur moins encore auprès d'un
juge du siège mais on peut en revanche
attirer l'attention et c'est aussi notre
heurô aujourd'hui sur les disparités il
y a aucune raison effectivement que les
femmes
soit euh les victimes au fond d'une
jurisprudence qui ne prendrait pas en
considération la réalité des euh
éléments pécuniares que vous nous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure aucune raison
euh je veux quand même parler une toute
petite secondes et puis ensuite je
réponds pardon il y a quelques questions
effectivement imag je trai très vite il
me reste quelques mots je quand même
rappeler l'intermédiation des pensur
alimentaires qui est quand même quelque
chose qui a été fait en en faveur des
femmes et qui et qui change leur vie
j'ai j'ai rencontré moi-même en
différents déplacements que j'ai pu
faire à la cafe notamment des femmes qui
mais avaient àaire
à des pères qui parfois avaient oublié
les obligations qui sont les leurs
l'intermédiation de pensions
alimentaires c'est quand même un un un
progrès permet vous le savez de de
sécuriser chaque mois le versement de la
pension alimentaire en prévenant le
risque d'impayer en 2022 je vous donne
ce chiffre j'ai pratiquement terminé 200
millions d'euros ont été recouvrés par
l'ARIPA la précarisation des femmes qui
représente 82 % des familles
monoparentales c'est un enjeu majeur
pour notre
société et ça nécessite une réponse
globale pour les soutenir je suivrai
ainsi avec la plus grande attention vos
travaux vos
recommandations pour en assurer une
parfaite diffusion au sein de
l'institution judiciaire ce qui sera
sans aucun doute l'occasion de redire
vos préoccupations quant au
déséquilibre jurisprudentiel qui peut
être parfois pour la fixation des
pensions alimentaires voilà madame la
Présidente Mesdames les sénatrices
monsur sénateur je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre à toutes les
questions des membres de votre
délégation merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre pour ce point très exhaustif je
sais que mes collègues brûlent de vous
poser des questions donc je vous poserai
les miennes qu'
qu'après je donne la parole tout d'abord
à an
suivront ensuite Laurence Rossignol puis
Joseline
Antoine merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le garde Dessau pour cette
audition devant notre délégation au
droits des femmes ça me donne l'occasion
de de vous remercier pour à la fois
l'engagement que vous avez pris depuis
la prise de fonction en tant que garde
des saau pour la lutte contre les
violences intrafamiliales et finalement
ça fait écho à à la discussion générale
hier de notre président Hervé Marseille
don le travail de cononstruction la loi
que j'ai porté en 2021 effectivement
elle elle elle a été construite grâce à
ce travail que nous avons eu ensemble et
je vous en remercie sur d'abord sur sur
l'IVG bien entendu et comme depuis
toutes ces discussions que nous avons pu
avoir au sein de la délégation et dans
l'hémicycle sur la
constitutionnalisation je voterai
favorablement en faveur de la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG euh oui
il y a peut-être eu une maladresse de
calendrier nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
débattre déjà longuement donc je pense
que le débat a été déjà assez riche et
et je je reste attaché à forcément à ce
droit fondamental pour moi c'est un
droit fondamental pour les générations à
venir et je suis heureuse d'entendre ce
matin votre détermination euh peut-être
revenir d'abord sur les ordonnances de
protection puisque en novembre 2023
beréranger Couillard annonçait qu'elles
allaient passer à 24h euh et la
requérante d'une ordonnance de
protection doit apporter la preuve de la
vraisemblance des violences et de
l'actualité du danger ce sont ces
preuves qui doivent caractériser de
manière indupitable l'existence de
violence et donc de danger et et là
c'est pas toujours le cas ces critères
posent des des enfin on a du mal à
appréhender ces critères et donc euh
parfois le véritable danger euh et
quelque chose une notion un petit peu
flou euh et euh or les les victimes sont
en fait déjà en danger euh de mort
parfois euh l'examen de la proposition
de loi d'Émilie chandleur suite au
rapport rougeevf porté avec notre
présidente euh a démontré l'utilité de
raccourcir ses délais donc moi j'ai
quelques questions qu'en est-il de
l'efficacité de l'ordonnance de
protection combien de victimes en
bénéfici et comptez-vous revoir les
critères de l'ordonnance de protection
vous avez évoqué la médecine légale on
sait qu'elle joue un rôle considérable
dans l'accompagnement des victimes mais
aussi pour détecter les victimes et pour
les enquêteurs euh je vais parler de
l'avend en 2021 l'équivalent temps plein
c'était 0,8 équivalent temps plein il y
avait 1200 actes de réaliser quand il y
en aurait pu en avoir 3000 pour le cas
des violences intrafamiliales donc quid
de la situation dans les autres
départements et avez-vous imaginé revoir
ce ce ces équivalents temp plein leur
nombre pour avoir une vraie médecine
légale dans les départements la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
depuis 2017 et l'annonce du président de
la République a pris une tournure
importante dans dans notre travail à la
fois législatif et dans la société la
libération de la parole des enfants a
pris elle un tour important au moment de
la création de la civise et euh la
civise a permis de libérer cette parole
des victimes mineures euh le départ
forcé du
co-président Édouard le juge Édouard
Durand a créé beaucoup d'émois beaucoup
de d'inquiétude par rapport à à cette à
cette
formidable je dirais à cet engouement et
cette libération de la parole des
victimes donc je le rappelle 160000
victur victimes mineures euh tout les
ans alors qu'avez-vous imaginé pour
lutter efficacement contre les
agressions sur mineur tout le monde
savait mais en général c'est tellement
inconcevable que personne le révèle
comment et avec quel outil mieux prendre
en compte la parole des enfants et il y
a un sujet qui revient régulièrement
c'est
l'imprescriptibilité alors que nous
avions voté des dispositions finalement
avec la prescriptibilité glissante
est-ce que c'est un sujet sur lequel
vous vous réfléchissez ou vous vous
n'avez pas bougé de position euh
peut-être pour finir puisque je sais que
le temps est est compté madame la
Présidente euh les femmes dans un petit
sujet plus léger on va dire femmes dans
les professions judiciaires puisque nous
avons porortter avec ma ma collègue et
présidente Dominique Verrien une
proposition de loi sur la place des
femmes dans dans les dans la haute
fonction publique et donc cette place
des femmes dans les postes à
responsabilité alors les femmes sont de
plus en plus nombreuses dans les
professions judiciaires donc en 2016 une
étude demandée par le Conseil supérieur
de la magistrature constatait que la
position de chef de juridiction montre
une forte masculinisation tout à fait
atypique eu égard à la féminisation du
corps au 1er janvier 2023 71 % des juges
en France sont des femmes donc la
magistrature est aujourd'hui une une
profession non mixte finalement mais
pour autant les postes de responsabilité
eux sont essentiellement occupés par des
hommes donc ben quelle solution quelle
qu'est-ce que vous avez imaginé pour que
les femmes occupent plus de
responsabilité aussi dans la profession
dans les professions judiciaires je vous
remercie j'ai fait aussi vite que j'ai
prés F de justice vous remercie je passe
la parole à Laurence
Rossignol merci madame la Présidente une
question
une remarque et une précision historique
et je commencerai d'abord par dire que
je j'adhère au propos du garde des saut
les choses avancent voilà c'est
incontestable elles avancent dans la
justice je peux vous signer si vous
voulez non non c'est vrai vos
collaborateurs
souris bonne journée bonne
[Rires]
journée
uneournée non non mais c'est c'est c'est
c'est incontestable et je je partage bon
nombre des des remarques des discussions
qui restent encore en cours et je les
questions de de définition du viol sont
piégeuses parce que je ne crois pas
qu'aucune définition nous mette à l'abri
d'un débat sur le consentement dans les
cours voilà c'est ni celle d'aujourd'hui
ni celle ni une autre et que par
ailleurs je pense aussi qu'on notre
définition est bien on pourrait
peut-être y ajouter une définition de ce
qu'el viol qui dirait le viol est une
relation sexuelle non consentie voilà ça
ça nuirait pas ça ne nuirait pas et ça
conserverait l'article tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui ceci étant posé ma question
va être plus précise et plus technique
je crois les cours criminels
départementales ont effectivement des
des résultats c'est vrai pour autant je
me demande si c'est la
meilleure instance pour toutes les
affaires je pense en particulier vous
savez que la délégation drit des femmes
du Sénat est très soucieuse des suites
des affaires sur la pornographie le pret
fren le procès French Bouake va arriver
probablement 2025 me dit-on maintenant
et à cet instant il est renvoyé devant
une cour criminelle
départementale je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit le bon endroit euh voilà mais c'est
le seul possible dans la voie
aujourd'hui j viens monsieur Gard des
saau seriez-vous d'accord à S pour
soutenir une proposition de loi qui en
fait étendrai les cours d'assis
spécialisé aux affaires de traite des
êtres humains en bande organisé
puisqueaujourd'hui les cours d'assis
spécialisé sont compétentes pour les
affaires de terrorisme et pour les
affaires de trafic de stupéfiants en
bande organisée est-ce que le trafic la
traite des êtres humains en bande
organisée pourrait être une de
compétence des cours d'assis spécialisés
et peut-être aussi des viols criels
je me suis m'étais fait la remarque au
moment où il y a eu le procès dans le
Vaucluse de cet homme où il y avait 51
prévenu si ma mémoire est bonne d'un
viol sériel celui qui s'est daté sa
femme et peut-être ça aurait mérité et
sur les affaires de de de traite des
êtres humains et les affaires
pardon non
Avignon ENIT le le les faits étaient
dans le
VUS celui qui drogué sa femme l' fait
violer par des gens voilà c'est celui-là
bref pe peu peu importe et donc je je je
me disais que sur les affaires French
bouak puis après on en aura d'autres
affaires concernant les viols dans
l'industrie pornographique un deuxième
procès qui vient derrière peut-être la
cour d'assise spécialement composée
serait la bonne voilà je vous demande
pas de répondre à cette question là à
cet instant parce qu'elle demande
effectivement d'être expertisé et de
travailler euh sur l'IVG euh la
constitionalisation de l'IVG je c'est
plus à mes collègue que je m'adresse
qu'à vous monsieur garde Dessau en fait
si jamais le Sénat se mettait en tête de
ralentir le garde a dit que on y
consacrera le temps qu'il faudra mais
d'adopter des amendements qui euh
fragiliseraient la possibilité
d'adoption à l'Assemblée nationale je
voudrais prévenir d'amblé les collègues
dans ce cas-là nous reviendrons à la
procédure d'initiative parlementaire une
proposition de loi a été adoptée au
Sénat il suffit que l'Assemblée
nationale la vote en l'état en l'état et
nous irons au référendum et pour ce ah
bah si ma ma compréhension de la
Constitution est que dès lors qu'une
proposition de loi a été adoptée dans
les mêmes termes par les deux assemblées
la suite et le référendum c'est la
Constitution le le le président de la
République ou le gouvernement peuvent
choisir entre le référendum ou le
Congrès lorsqu'il s'agit d'un projet de
loi constitutionnelle donc d'initiative
gouvernementale s'il s'agit d'une
initiative parlementaire c'est
systématiquement le référendum et je ne
vois pas comment le président de la
République pourrait décider de ne pas
recourir au référendum après que la que
nous ayons satisfait à la double
exigence d'un vote conforme dans les
deux assemblées et en ce qui nous
concerne Parlement
militante féministe défenseuse du libre
choix nous n'avons pas peur du
référendum donc ce n'est pas notre
premier choix mais si nous devions en
arriver là nous irons voilà ces choses
sont claires et j'espère que ça va
infuser dans les réflexions de nos
collègues du Sénat et enfin dernière
chose c'est juste un petit rappel
historique euh l'ARIPA a été créé en
2016 al c'est pas que je sois
sourcilleuse et cetera mais de temps en
temps de temps en temps se rappeler
qu'elle a été considérablement améliorée
depuis 2006 que elle a été le travail
engagé a été poursuivi la Ripa et a
été fourni de nouveaux collaborateurs
des nouvelles lois sont venu mais elle a
été créée en
2016 euh ben on on fait toutes les
questions et vous répondez ensuite donc
Joceline Antoine et qui sera suivi par
Olivier
richardci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le garde des saau je vais être
très bref puisque vous avez répondu en
grande partie à ce que je voulais ce
dont je voulais vous entretenir sur
l'actualité actuelle de la directive
européenne sur les violences faites aux
femmes dont l'article 5 prévoit
d'instaurer donc la une définition
pénale unique de viol fondé sur la sur
la notion de
consentement l'opposition de la France
me semble quand même un petit peu
problématique
parce qu'elle rentre en contradiction
avec la convention d'Istanbul du Conseil
de l'Europe que la France a
signé en 2014 et qui impose aux
États-membres de criminaliser les actes
sexuels non consentis alors bien sûr il
ne
s'agit que d'une
convention
euh j'ai bien entendu votre exposé sur
l'aspect de la démion juridique du viol
mais bon afin de protéger au mieux les
victimes ne conviendrait-il pas de
garder les notions de menace violence
contrainte et surprise tel que le
prévoit notre droit et qui effectivement
euh est un des plus contraignants
d'Europe euh mais également de
considérer en plus que l'absence de
consentement et légalement constitutive
d'un viol parce que dans l'état d'esprit
des victimes c'est quand même pas tout à
fait la même chose euh et je pense que
ça encouragerait aussi les femmes à
porter plan plus facilement dans la
démarche psychologique voilà je vous
remercie Olivia Richard merci présidente
monsieur le garde des saau sénatrice des
Français établieurs de France je suis
très sensible au rayonnement de la
France sur la scène
internationale et dès lors l'inscription
de l'IVG dans la Constitution me paraît
me paraîtrait être un symbole très
fort et une réaffirmation d'un
attachement à des valeurs humaniste
indispensable donc je voterai bien
entendu ce texte en espérant qu'il qu'il
arrive vite et qu'il ne fasse pas
l'objet d'une procédure plus compliquée
même si en effet elle serait
possible donc les Françaises établi hors
de France pardon de de parler d'elle
parce que c'est une population qui est
lointaine m connue mais comment accéder
à l'IVG dans des pays où c'est
totalement interdit ça implique de
rentrer en France pourquoi le Sénat
avait adopté ad un amendement à
l'occasion de la discussion budgétaire
qui a disparu à la faveur d'un 493 qui
prévoyait la possibilité de rapatrier
les femmes qui devaient rentrer en
France pour bénéficier de cela vous le
savez il y a des délais contraints je
regrette la disarition de cette
disposition deuxième chose nous avons
entendu le le Premier ministre parler de
la possibilité de porter plainte en
ligne là encore des ce serait très
précieux pour les femmes françaises à
étranger qui ne peuvent pas aller porter
plainte au consulat
et ça pose néanmoins le problème nous
avons des conventions internationales
qui interdisent de déplacer les enfants
de façon j'allais dire unilatérale donc
un mari violent car généralement ce sont
les maris qui sont violents euh a des
droits sur ses enfants de
façon en tout cas en fonction de la dro
la loi locale mais même du droit
français et donc une femme qui tente de
rentrer en France pour échapper à son
bourreau emmène ses enfants et se
retrouve euh elle-même coupable d'un
d'un déplacement illicite d'enfant euh
les agents du ministère des Affaires
étrangère plus particulier le Bureau
d'aide aux familles en lien avec votre
ministère tente d'expliquer aux
autorités françaises locales lors du
retour que non ce ne sont pas des
enlèvements non c'est une mise à l'abri
et néanmoins il faut une évolution
législative pour sécuriser et permettre
euh le retour en France euh de des
femmes qui parfois n'ont même pas de
famille he se retrouvent totalement
isolé les Français l'étrangers sont loin
d'être tous des
expatriés lorsqu'ell le sont
c'est-à-dire on a encore beaucoup de
femmes qui suivent leur mari à
l'étranger elles dépendent pour la
légalité de leur situation la régularité
de leur situation du visa du conjoint
qui trouve encore un moyen de pression
supplémentaire parceque retirer le
passeport ne suffit plus pour fragiliser
leur situation et il m'a été rapporté
des cas dans certains pays où en cas de
séparation bien sûr la femme perd son
visa et doit repartir mais où les
enfants sont invités à rester bon
d'autres cas encore où le mari quitte la
femme quitte le pays dénonce le visa de
son épouse et donc de ses enfants qui se
retrouvent irrégulier et doivent payer
une asreinte journ bref il y a des
situations inextricables et tout est
encore pire à l'étranger voilà merci
merci pour votre
attention je vous laisse la parole pour
répondre à ces nombreuses questions
monsieur le
ministre il est déjà merci madame la
présidente madame la sénatrice
billon d'abord merci pour vos gentils
mots à propos de
notre collaboration efficace et
effective
texte que vous avez que vous nous avez
présenté et qui a permis me semble-t-il
de faire beaucoup évoluer les choses
nous avons dit
clairement
que un homme ne peut plus dire qu'une
gamine de 14 ans était
consentante exception faite de notre
petit
amendement Roméo Roméo et Juliette
euh qui a été disons-le
débattu euh la notion de danger sur sur
l'ordonnance de de protection est une
exigence
constitutionnelle alors il faut qu'on
trouve pas si simple que cela mais je
pense que nous avons trouvé un
équilibre un équilibre entre les
atteintes aux libertés fondamentales
parce que ça va très vite et que Y a se
poser la question du contradictoire
parce que
bon on prend quelqu'un par la peau du
dos on le on le vire du domicile conjugé
il faut qu'il y ait aussi matière à ce
que le contradictoire puisse à un moment
s'exercer qu'il puisse faire valoir ses
droit donc il y avait l'équilibre
indispensable entre une une une une
atteinte aux liberté fondamental sans
déclaration de culpabilité je le
rappelle parce que on est dans de
l'extrême urgence donc le procureur
intervient Phe de contradictoire ensuite
et la Cour de cassation a dit je je vous
transmettrai la la
décision que la constitutionnalité euh
était au fond subordonné à l'existence
d'un danger alors ensuite vient la
définition de ce qui est un danger
j'entends tout ce que vous me dites mais
euh ce cette proposition de loi doit
doit être examinée dans les dans les
heures qui viennent devait dans les
jours qui viennent un mois de mars ça a
été reporté mais et il n'était pas
exclus qu'elle soit débattue dès hier et
puis pour cause d'embouteillage si si si
j'ose dire ça été reporté au mois de
mars mais ce n'est pas à vous que je
vais dire qu'il y aura aussi un travail
parlementaire et qu'il aura aussi mais
comme d'habitude
euh pour objet d'enrichir le
texte
bon potentiellement
euh donc
tout ça va être discuté la recherche
pour moi c'est celle d'un équilibre sans
perdre de
l'efficacité je dois dire que jusqu'à
maintenant on a de façon drastique
réduit les
délais et il est indispensable oui qu'on
puisse intervenir en cas de de de danger
d'urgence
avec les difficultés de définir des
concepts comme Cuxa mais moi je ne doute
pas une seule seconde que nous allons y
parvenir et que cette
ordonnance euh ultra rapide est au fond
d'une une grande nécessité et et et nous
le savons bon sur la médecine légale
c'est c'est j'ai j'ai j'ai eu des
échanges déjà avec la ma collègue
chargée de la Santé bon on est là sur de
de l'interministériel effectivement on a
beaucoup de choses à renforcer je je je
il y a ce sujet que vous évoquez il y a
le sujet de la psychiatrie également est
un sujet majeur très imbriqué
avec la détention par exemple mais aussi
la
prévention donc là-dessus on est en
train de de de travailler on a à
l'esprit l'un et l'autre que il est
indispensable que nous
renforcions tout ce qui permet
euh aux femmes victimes d'avoir accès à
la la médecine
égal vous m'avez interrogé encore sur la
la féminisation de la magistrature bien
alors si si j'étais cynique ce que je ne
suis pas je vous dirais laissons faire
les choses euh quand je vais aux
prestations de serment
des auditeurs de justice je suis
toujours surpris quand il y a un garçon
qui vient faire le petit selfie il y en
a plus c'est pratiquement exclusivement
féminin hein hein le barreau s'oriente
aussi vers cela bon et moi en ce qui me
concerne euh j'ai proposé au Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature euh des
procureurs procureurs généraux qui sont
des femmes bon et je dois vous dire je
sais pas si c'est rassurant mais c'est
une réalité euh mon cabinet est
composé très majoritairement de femmes
femmes
magistrat et enfin euh pour être un peu
plus sérieux et répondre à vos
préoccupations dans le PJ lo que vous
avez voté on a pris un certain nombre de
dispositions pour que non seulement les
femmes qui sont magistrates soient
magistrates évidemment mais qu'elles
puissent accéder évidemment euh à au
postees hiérarchique qui leur sont d
voilà ce que je peux vous répondre euh
madame madame Rossignol madame Rossignol
oui har pas rendons rendons à César mais
oui long temp voilà non mais et
d'ailleurs non mais je je n'en ai pas
fait une
appropriation mensongère concédezle moi
j'ai évoqué haripa je oui il me plaît de
vous dire à cet instant que je sais qui
est à l'origine
d'aripa vous posez des moi vous savez je
suis je demande qu' être convaincu
donc la question des des des des
cours
spécialisés vous avez évoqué le Terrot
terrorisme vous avez évoqué le
stupéfiant bande
organisée je suis saisi d'une question
en ce moment on ne rien vous cacher
parce queon me dit mais quand on
trafique des stupes en bande organisé
c'est la cour
d'assise spéciale mais quand deux
trafiquants de stup
s'entretuent c'est le la cour d'assise
traditionnelle est-ce qu'il y a pas là
Monsieur le Ministre une difficulté on
réfléchit là-dessus et de la même façon
on peut réfléchir à ce que vous dites
pas maintenant je ouais ouais mais
j'entends bien mais là aussi l'équilibre
est toujours difficile à trouver parce
que on m'a déjà beaucoup
reproché nétait pas à l'initiative de ça
mais j'ai j'ai j'ai ensuite évidemment
été totalement engagé sur les cours
criminales départementales pour les
raisons que j'ai évoqué m'a beaucoup
reproché de vous vouloir tuer la cour
d'assise traditionnelle à cela je
répondais que j'avais renforcé la
souveraineté
populaire puisque j'avais exigé que dans
le cadre de la définition d'une
culpabilité il y ait une majorité de
jurist ce qui n'était plus le cas
bon alors il faut aussi qu'on garde
cette cour d'assise parce que il est
important dans une grande démocratie que
au fond le peuple au nom de qui on rend
la justice puisse y participer mais mais
ce que vous dites mérite expertise cri
ouais je j'entends j'entends c'est vrai
que traite des êtres humains en bande
organisé bon l'idée de de ces
juridictions spécialisées c'est pour
protéger les jurés d'ailleurs hein bon
on a eu un certain nombre d'affaires où
les magistrats professionnels euh on a
considéré qu'ils
étaient mieux à même de faire face à une
criminalité du du haut du spectre comme
on dit en langage technocratique ça que
on avait eu vent de ce que des jurés
pouvaiit être menacés d'ailleurs on
avait parfois la difficulté qui était de
les
réunir voilà et on a vu des défections
d'ailleurs donc je suis opposé à rien a
priori on va on va réfléchir on peut
même réfléchir ensemble vous savez je le
redis madame Rossin je vousou l'ai déjà
dit que la porte de la Chancellerie est
est ouverte
bah oui je sais non mais vous vous dites
AR pas et moi je dis la porte est
ouverte chacun dit son petit truc aussi
parce que c'est vrai bon voilà
hein sur la question madame la sénatrice
Antoine
de de
l'Europe
bon d'ailleurs c'est une question qui
est aussi posée par Madame Rossignol
qu'il faudrait pas ajouter dans le texte
que le viol est une rel non consentie je
je alors d'emblé mais sans y avoir
réfléchi davantage je pense que la
définition du viol tel que nous l'avons
dans notre code pénal nécessairement
mais implicitement rappelle le défaut de
consentement puisque on parle de
violence on parle de de de surprise par
exemple de contraintte bon bien sûr donc
ce sont des choses qui sont me
semble-t-il claires je suis pas
insensible à l'idée euh d'être peut-être
plus pédagogue auprès des victimes ça se
réfléchit moi je ne suis contre rien
mais ce que je veux réaffirmer ici parce
que j'ai vu toute une polémique
monter que le Gard des saau entre autres
gouvernement auquel il
appartient serait rétrograde frileux sur
ces questions
bon c'est pas un
argument dont on peut faire son beur
électoraliste ma préoccupation je l'ai
dit c'est la votre aussi je suis
vraiment très heureux de de d'avoir
entendu ce que vous aviez à dire sur
cette question c'est faisons attention
peit tropérain parfois malembrasse et au
fond vouloir protéger le dire et puis se
voir au final opposer une décision qui
serait une décision qui s'imposerait à
tous de la Cour de justice je leaurais
dit c'est une question de compétence et
j'ai j'ai j'ai trouvé un peu pas
utiliser les grands mots les mots qui
fchent mais un peu malhonnête la
présentation qui a parfois été faites
des
choses au fond j'entendais nous nous
avons les solutions nous nous protégeons
les femmes nous et nous et nous et le
gouvernement est en retrait non pas du
tout le gouvernement il dit faisons très
attention à ce que ce que nous essayons
de de construire au au quotidien et y a
encore des failles et y a encore
beaucoup de boulot et c'est un combat
qui malheureusement déjà jamais terminé
n'aboutissent pas à pire que ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'une
législation qui sait ce que c'est que le
viol et qu'il le reprime et qu'il le
réprime de façon plus sévère que les
autres pays européens alors faire de la
petite polache là-dessus ça m'a un peu
chagriné parce que je le redis
d'ailleurs vous savez si vous êtes au
fait du
sujet qu'il y a de vraies discussions de
juristes de très très haut niveau la
question c'est celle de la compétence et
en déplais à certains euh bah cette
question là elle mérite quand même
d'être examinée on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi moi je n'ai pas envie
évidemment que on fasse n'importe quoi
et qu'au fond le résultat obtenu soit
pire que ce que nous avons madame
Richard la la la plainte en
ligne pour l'étranger n'est pas prévu
maintenant mais il faut qu'on y
travaille et
alors les les sujets que vous évoquez
sont pour moi et pour le ministère à
casse-tête sagisse des questions
d'adoption euh alors vous me dites
changer la législation alors la
difficulté c'est que notre législation
n'a pas vocation s'appliquer dans des
pays souverains et donc il y a la voie
évidemment de l'évolution législative
pour faciliter le parcours de femmes qui
veulent revenir en France tout ça on
peut l'envisager et moi si vous avez des
propositions à me faire je suis tout à
fait preneur en revanche on est
davantage sur du du du du traité fatil
bilatéral multilatéral pour essayer
d'obtenir aussi de nos partenaires
une forme de réciprocité par exemple et
de permettre que une femme qui revient
avec ses enfants parfois d'ailleurs dans
le cadre d'une décision de justice
rendue en France par un un juge français
ne fasse pas l'objet de tracasserie
tracasserie c'est doucement euphémique
hein vous vous vous l'avez dit j'étais
confronté à une question de de
d'adoption c'est un véritable casse-tê
parce que on ne peut pas opposer si
j'ose dire même si on essaie de le faire
dans la dans la discussion dans la
tractation on peut pas opposer euh euh
notre législation à d'autres pays mais
euh ça m'intéresse beaucoup que vous
veniez me faire part des choses qui à
votre sens pourrai évoluer pour
permettre à nos compatriotes qui sont à
l'étranger euh d'être LTI si j'ose dire
à meilleur enseigne
euh à qui dois-je encore répondre et
bien c'est à vous madame la
Présidente revient de conclure et en
fait ce sera pas quelques questions mais
plutôt quelques remarques à la suite de
cette audition que je m'étais noté au f
à mesure de votre intervention vous avez
évoqué la justice patrimoniale il se
trouve que c'est une
proposition que probablement notre
groupe devrait porter le groupe Union
centriste en tout cas il fait partie des
choix qui nous ont été proposés et le
vote est en cours et j'espère en tout
cas personnellement j'y suis très
favorable et j'ai voter pour ce texte et
je crois que nous avons de bonnes
chances qu'il puisse être inscrit dans
une niche prochaine de l'Union centriste
sur les pôle vif j'avais quelque chose à
à préciser finalement pour être allé en
Espagne et comme vous le dites c'est
toujours l'exemple finalement quand je
vois les pôles puisque aujourd'hui je
suis invité dans un certain nombre de
juridictions pour voir ces pôles se
mettre en place ou rencontrer les
présidents de tribunaux ou les
procureurs généraux nous allons plus
loin finalement que ce que fait l'
puisque en Espagne même si c'est dans un
même bâtiment le pénal et le civil ne se
parlent pas alors que là le pénal et le
civil vont se parler pour aller
effectivement dans le sens que nous
souhaitions c'est que ce soit une une
affaire globale qui soit traité dans
toutes ces dimensions femm homm enfant
et effectivement nous sommes nous nous
allons plus loin et et je suis très
heureuse de faire ce ce Tour de France
en ce moment euh un petit élément qui
m'a été signalé vous savez qu'il y a
toujours des gens qui nous suivent à
l'extérieur sur le fait qu'il y a eu un
petit un sondage qui a été fait sur le
contrôle coercitif et de savoir s'il
devrait faire partie de notre arsenal
pénal en tout cas il semblerait 96 % des
personnes soient prononcé pour je pense
que de toute façon c'est effectivement
un sujet à travailler puisque l'avantage
du contrôle coercitif et je sais que nos
gendarmes de liyumne par exemple s'y
forment c'est ce sont des éléments de
preuve pour bien montrer qu'il n'y a pas
d'égalité il n'y a pas de parole contre
parole mais bien un auteur qui a mis en
place tout un système pour pouvoir
mettre sa victime sous emprise et on
fait porter c'est un peu pour ça que
j'étais heureuse de vous entendre sur le
viol on fait porter sur l'auteur la
responsabilité de ces actes et non pas
sur la victime à savoir si elle était
sousempris si machin si truc
euh sur et d'ailleurs puisque nous
parlons de formation à ces sujets-l je
je pense que ces formations aideront
aussi beaucoup à mieux poursuivre les
viols et à probablement avoir un petit
peu moins de classements sans suite dont
on on dit souvent qu'effectivement c'est
manque de preuve mais parfois euh en
tout cas j'ai un un cas bien précis en
tête où globalement on est à peu près
assuré quand même que le monsieur s'est
très mal comporté et probablement pas
qu'avec la personne qui a osé aller
porter plainte le classement sans suite
est très gênant parce que bah
globalement si on poursuit pas on sait
qu'il va continuer et donc c'est vrai
que ce manque de preuve ou de de le le
le fait de pas creuser et je pense que
en étant mieux formé on trouve plus
d'éléments également sur le comportement
des auteurs sur la remarque de notre
collègue Laurence Rossignol
effectivement que je comprends
parfaitement parce que le procès entre
autes French buqueé et en tout cas tout
ce qui est porno ça mérite d'être
franchement publque qu' ait une grosse
publicité autour pour montrer que non on
ne fait pas n'importe quoi et que oui le
porno c'est de la violence en tout cas
dans dans ces sujetsl euh donc voilà et
pour conclure sur l'ARIPA alors moi
j'avais déjà fait la même réflexion sur
les maisons France service dont je
voyais que parfois certains se
gargarisaient et en oubliant qu'il y
avait les maisons de service au public
qui étaient ouvertes quand même depuis
quelques années
euh mais je voulais et voilà donc des
choses qui se qui se développent euh
donc effectivement rendons à César je
sur l'ARIPA vous avez mentionné
effectivement des montants nous y
reviendrons quand nous remettrons notre
rapport sur les familles monoparentales
vous avez suivi l'audition d'Eric Dupont
moriti le garde des saau par la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
Sénat les détails et les analyses sont à
retrouver sur notre site publsenat.fr
quant à moi je vous souhaite une très
belle journée sur les chaînes
[Musique]
parlementaires